[Musique]
tout un livre
très intéressant si un côté poèmes et
qui s'explique
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui se
sent seul et qui trouve une amie et si
le bail heureuse à vos élèves et pas
d'amis elle excelle et puis quand la
rentrée contre lui mais voilà il ya les
plus belles écrite et je ne regarde
enfin c'est en noir
en noir et blanc et puis ça change un
peu habituelle
[Musique]
petite fille s'appelle colette qui mrd
et qui a donné un carton
il y avait un oiseau elle dit qu'elle
cherche moi de oui on est cependant sans
retour et puis à la fin et puis on s'en
rend compte
ce mensonge est permis et rennes
et
les couleurs avec les images en noir
jaune et blanc ça fait joli avec les
bulles aussi comme d'une arme ça dit
qu'il faut sortir un peu et couple va
parler avec les gens et communiquer
plutôt que rester dans le canapé tout le
premier regarder la télé voix des sports
bacar commande d'abord jean ping en fait
elle donne des images et elle ne veut
pas varié maintenant à elle habite à la
campagne qu'elle a perdu tous ses amis
et puis maintenant il essaye de s'isoler
sur son blog
et puis elle essaie de faire voter oui
mais dans le temps mais vous allez vous
mettre aux ailes et j'allais voir le
soir parce que voilà message que cenovus
on y lire c'est pas la même mise en page
que d'habitude
là non parce qu'il ya les messages sur
comme sur un blog
après ya toujours les bd il ya des
écritures comme c'était sur un corner je
trouve ça vraiment réaliste puis c'est
joli mais avec des dimensions
il est bien super
[Musique]